hello everybody hello hello oh chat's dead let me fix you guys real quick give me a sec clear see i can bring people back to life these aren't just murder weapons but but good morning dragons hello today is another another day of the dokey smp before I start,
I want to give a huge shout out to CloudNord because they are the ones that are providing the servers for the Doki SMP for all of us or all the Dragoons here playing on the server.
For those who are wondering, what is the Doki SMP?
Basically, it is a Minecraft server that me and my team are running for the Dragoons and for the community.
So the way to join the Dragoon to be a member so if you're already a member you already have uh you can follow the instructions pinned in the comment uh pinned in the chat and pinned in the linkedin description that gives you the instructions on how to join the um the doki smp minecraft server so um i'll basically be streaming the server once every month to check up on you guys and also like if there's any events or anything in the future um it'll be basically i'll stream it um and everything so yeah it's a A great way to interact,
well, chance to interact with me on the server.
And, yeah, it's basically a fun time for everybody, for the Dragoons.
What else do I want to talk about other than the Doki SMP?
Oh, yes.
That update.
So, after my Haudenosaunee stream, you know, I took him out for walkies and everything.
We had a little adventure.
During our walkies.
He took me, like, further.
You know, like, I don't know.
After Hall Night, I had the adrenaline in me.
And I was like, you know what?
Even though it's, like, 11 p.m., we're going to have a little adventure late at night.
I 11...
Okay.
The more I talk about it, the more I realize I really should not be alive.
Anyway, I was like, it's 11 p.m.
Time to have a little adventure.
with my dog late at night.
It's in a very safe neighborhood, I think.
I just arrived.
It was 200 years ago.
My parents would abandon me in the forest because they would know I would not, it was not worth raising me.
It's okay.
I have dad there to protect me, my tiny ass dog.
And all he could do is just, I guess he would just bark them away.
Anyway.
Anyway, so I decided, I was like, oh man, I had a good holiday night.
She's like, I had a good silk song stream today.
Let me go out at 11 p.m.
to walk my dog and also, like, have a little adventure outside and explore a little bit of the neighborhood.
He's trying his best.
My old injured small dog will protect me, guys.
It's not like he had one back surgery, another misaligned disc on his neck or anything and he is seven years old now but don't worry he'll protect me anyway so um during the during the walkies uh nah he'd win so during the walkies uh when i was you know he was doing his usual pee and poop but while he was pooping he had a little accident what kind of accident would you might you wonder so when he was pooping he somehow lost his balance i've never seen this before like seven years he somehow lost his balance in the middle of pooping fell to the side while he's still pooping got back up and then continue to poop.
What did you, how did you lose your balance?
oh, it was dark.
He could not see a donkey.
You decided to walk him at 11 p.m.
London Bridge is falling down.
Falling down.
And he like played it off.
It was like nothing happened.
He was like, oh, I was just a regular old day for me uh but yes he literally like tipped over to his side because he lost he somehow i don't even know how he lost his balance it's mostly a flat floor it's mostly like a flat surface so i don't know what happened um i'm meant to do that anyway so uh and you expose him to everyone he thought it was a safe space dokey how dare you tell the story did he even sent to this he thought it was just a private moment between you and him and you had to tell the story to everyone that's messed up dokey not using him for content that poor old man i can't believe you would you would abuse the elderly like this for content Imagine if I exposed my kids a bathroom stories on stream.
Okay, yeah, anyway.
So, yeah, he, like, tipped over to the side.
And he just kept, he just got back up and just, he just, like, nothing happened.
Anyway, while we were on our little late night, late night adventure, I was walking, you know, I was walking past down, like, several streets.
And when we were walking back, uh there was like a yeah i was walking past a grocery store um that's not near my place because we walked pretty far
um and uh and so i heard a noise on in the trash can i was like the fuck is that like i was just like what the fuck is that noise and so dad i just stopped because i was like was there something in the trash can and out from the trash can came a little ratatouille a little a little fucking remy from ratatouille came out of the trash can um chucked up whatever the fuck he was holding he chucked it on the ground and then dropped down looked at dad and dad and dad was just like what the fuck because i was like what the fuck that was like what the fuck And then,
like, we were just looking at it.
And then he, like, picked up the food and just ran into the bushes.
And then Dad reacted.
But very slow reaction.
And then he fucking reacted after the rat ran away.
So I'm just like, what the fuck was that?
Like, oh, now you react.
What if that rat had a knife?
What?
What if he had a knife?
You're reacting after he runs away.
Like, yeah, you better run.
I was like, yeah, that's right.
He was shook.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm around with a knife.
Then he'd be out right.
He can't outrun me when I have him on the leash.
If anything, I'll pull him back and then I'll be in front.
Had to do a vibe check first.
I was like, I was like, you're supposed to bike with.
the rat comes up.
Not after the rat runs away, dad.
Like, he could have had a gun.
Excuse him for not reacting at freaking midnight.
Your poor poor dog.
Don't blame him.
He just has 300 MS ping from high to his leg and stay out.
Yeah, that's right.
Run.
Um, but yeah, that was was my late night adventures uh with my dog um and we arrived safely home it might have been midnight but we were it was midnight but we were safely home guys you know i maybe i should not have had my little adventure at around 11 to midnight i think that was a very bad idea it's a miracle that I have survived this long with all my with all my quirky little ideas that I have then then you have the super chat thank you thank you when I lived in New York City the rats got into my protein powder I caught one and it was the size of a small dog holy fuck what that rat was fucking lifting weights holy shit I was on some goddamn steroids at that point.
Vela, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh yeah, apparently the plague is back.
Because I was telling this I was telling this rat story to one of my friends.
And then they were like, oh yeah, maybe they should kill off all the rats in that neighborhood.
That's not good.
I was like, oh, that's fucked up, bro.
And then my friend was like, did you not hear the plague back i was like what and i was like what do you mean i thought the plague was just a thing in the medieval times we're in 2025 what what do you mean the plague is back i was so confused yeah so apparently um recently there was a case in california where um someone died from the plague the plague sequel yeah and so um so like yeah a woman died in california it's just california things but a woman died in california from the plague i'm like but how just like how is it i guess we forget that it was supposed to be gone how did it it's like measles like we just some people just stopped it doing stop being vaccinated to measles and just came back.
I was just like, they could do that.
They could just come back.
What's the point of having it eradicated if it just comes back?
That is not eradication.
It was just on a very long vacation.
Like instead of eradication, it was just on a vacation.
And it just, it can just come back.
Like, I, can we get rid of California?
Yeah, so um so yeah anyway so that's how i found out that's just another new fear of mine i just found out that the plague can just come back now and it could be it could come to any one of and there's rats in my neighborhood so that's really good news there's apparently a bunch of rats in my neighborhood and the plague is back so um let's just Oh,
none of the rats there are like carriers for the plague.
Rabies is way worse, but to get rabies, you just gotta be bit by a wild animal.
And as long as I don't go outside, that's never gonna happen.
And I know dad doesn't have rabies, so he won't fucking give me rabies.
You will be missed.
It's just a little plague, Toki.
Everything will be fine.
No, I don't go to the dog park anymore Because they put a curfew at the dog park And then they were like If we find you Because sometimes I go to the dog park At like 3 in the morning To take dad for walkies If I'm having a late Super late night of work And they recently put a curfew At the dog park And they're like If we see you Going to the dog park After this time you will be fine and we have cameras and then i was like well guess i'm fucking not going to the dog park anymore so so i haven't been at a dog park here for a while ever since they um do not go to the dog park at three in the morning it was very safe though that was the reason why i went to the dog part during late at night because like it was because like I couldn't go to the dog part through um um the passageway through my apartment so like my apartment had like a small passageway to the dog part which and then like all I had to do was just go outside for just a little bit and then I'll be there um so that's why I felt
like very safe going there but then now now they're like oh we have a curfew because apparently it wasn't just me guys other people were also going to the dog park after like after like 11 p.m um and because of that the neighbors like the people who were like who were like uh stationed who were living like close to the dog park were were like complaining about it because apparently there were some very rowdy dogs at the dog park um after 11 p.m and so they had to be more strict with the curfew and i know it wasn't me and dad because dad says nothing unless unless there's another dog he doesn't care he just does his thing and then leaves and there's no other dog at three in the morning so i i know that we weren't the problem because there's no other dogs at three in the morning at the dog part so like we weren't the ones that caused the curfew so i don't know a gang of dogs like was just being way too rowdy late at night um so so i i that means that there were other dogs that were
barking and causing a scene you know the use that the there were other use that the dog part that were causing a scene the dog crew um that were giving noise complaints to the neighbors so now that now that they put a curfew they're like and they're like we have cameras and we will find you and we find who you are.
I was like, oh, I don't risk that.
So I just like, I don't take him to the dog park anymore.
And anyway, he doesn't, can't even play fetch anyway.
So the only reason why I go to a dog park was just to play fetch with him.
Um, but now that he's like, you know, he's like that, that's SpongeBob character in, uh, that SpongeBob character where he's like, if I breathe, I snap 20 bones in my body.
Now that dad is like that, there's no reason to go like, Like, yeah, 10th date of third time.
I can't go to the dog park.
I can't really go to the dog park anymore and play fetch because, like, I don't want to risk anything.
Anyway, it's Minecraft time.
That was a dad update for today.
And also, like, a concern for all of you guys about my...
Another concern for you guys about my lack of survival and things.
Oh, yeah.
This is very out of topic.
Um, I really want to show you guys this picture because I don't keep up with Pokemon anymore and I really I literally thought this was a shitpost like but for those who don't keep up with Pokemon anymore like this is a real Pokemon design.
I this was apparently for Pokemon Sword and Shield and it's like what the villain what is it is it the villains for Sword.
style is based upon uh pokemon sword and shield so they're like how do we make them how do we make them look like you know represent a sword and shield why don't we just make the hair i thought they were the pokemon that yeah turkey it's a miracle you're still alive at this point You're good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, Matt.
Thank you The super chat.
Thank you.
I hope we have really good insurance sounds very stressful.
I think we need to visit a massage parlor.
Thank you.
Um, Patrick Esther, you're thinking the super chat.
You're not supposed to like them.
And they only appear for one hour of content.
Even okay.
Okay.
Like I, I can't believe we went from the subway I like it makes me so sad because I was okay I would say I was very obsessed with the Subway Brothers like they were like my favorite um they were like my favorite character design of any trainer um yeah they were actually peak and everything was just downhill from there after the Subway Bros I it makes me so sad because Subway Brothers were actually like one of the best designs they've ever made for like twin brothers and then and then they made this you know them you know that meme where it was like um the hr meme where you're like hr please send help when they came out real uh they gave me the super chat thank you thank you you more met swordward and shield bird.
Wait till you meet Gunther.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For real and for real, I think those guys were actually in this shit.
Wait, they were actually called sword bird and shield bird?
You're, no.
I thought you were fucking with, no way.
Okay.
Sword bird and shield bird.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Sword word and shield I have to faint.
So annoying.
Oh, you know what's even sad?
When they try to make a trainer card for them and they try to keep it very serious.
The artist tried so hard.
You know this artist was trying so hard to make this card even remotely look good.
God, they're stupid people.
fucking air oh i feel so bad for the you know they were trying so very hard to try and um what's the word recover from this from from this god awful design yeah what's that word they were trying to fix fix what can't be god wait a minute oh wait okay oh god okay i thought that was a i thought that was real I couldn't I meant that's not real thank God someone made a chip post character of Gunther with a gun hairstyle yeah they're uh Gunther thank God he's fake I almost believed it honestly I don't laughy but thank you for the super chat thank you thank you can you promise me that you won't tax the borderlands and Doki S&P I'm a regular super chatter isn't that taxation end up no everyone needs to be taxed it's everyone is equal in Doki land And that means everyone has to be taxed to,
um, so that Doki Land will continue to exist.
We all have to play a part, guys.
There's no exceptions in Doki Land.
All right, let's see.
Unless you're the rich, then, like, your tax, uh, then, then don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Very Canadian of you.
got you we yeah to real turkey to real there was another pokemon card i wanted i saw but it was so it was so small i wanted to like see the oh yeah there it is is there a bigger version of this i mean like they tried their best to salvage it but like i love how his head hair is so long like they have to be like okay but we gotta make sure like the physics apply um Look,
I will say that I do indeed take bribes.
A corrupt government is a good government.
Like, I like how his hair is super floppy because they're like, no, we still have to figure out the physics in Pokemon hair.
All right, let's actually play Minecraft.
All right, I don't remember exactly the sound.
I didn't save the sound settings for Minecraft, so the sound guy is here.
Just make sure, let me know if everything's okay.
Alright, let's go play.
Some music, too.
Where's my music at?
There we go.
Some nice relaxing piano music.
Hello.
Proceed.
I'll have to download a custom pack.
I forgot about it.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
home.
Yeah, that's right.
King Doki Bird is here.
That's right.
Long live the king.
Yes, yes.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Why do I have a German flag?
Oh, I forgot.
Sorry.
I forgot to change my skin again.
I keep forgetting.
Emperor Doki Bac...
Emperor Joke-Bird is here, guys.
What am I on?
What is this?
What is on me right now?
What the...
Oh, okay, it's just a hook.
Don't worry.
Emperor Joke-Bird has returned from the lands.
Here to collect the taxes from the people.
Alright, let's go.
Let's grab this.
And then put...
Put some shoes on.
Now they will never know.
They'll never know where I am.
Alright, let's see.
Where's my land?
Alright, mods!
TP me to Doki Land!
I heard some of my mods have claimed Doki Land.
TP me to Doki Land right now.
Mods!
Okay.
Oh yes, for those who don't know, I accidentally destroyed the server last time so um because i accidentally destroyed the server the entire server is new so so this is a new server now so this is jokiland why is there so many signs what the fuck is what is that croaky i swear to god paid this week rent is to pay or i double it please please might evict this way excuse me why why am I getting evicted this is my land two porters yet not enough to pay rent we're mods are you not paying rent wait why are we paying rent this is my land we don't even have ac why we here hey croaky rents do pay up croaky Red is too.
Can you pay?
How long have you been missing Red?
Last chance where's the money?
Secrets?
Okay.
I also wrote a message.
Cactus was right about you.
Free loader.
Am I?
Where am I?
Is this not Doki land?
Whose land is this?
Damn, being a landlord is so rough.
Who is my is this I don't even know all right I've lost track I thought this was Doki land I know that I know that like okay oh you grabbed the oh okay so this is this is a temporary okay this is awkward because the moment you you unclaimed this oh unclaimed this area um then then like someone else is gonna claim it okay someone give me their light tra right now and in the name of joki in the name of jokiland someone someone give me their light tra off their backs i don't care how you're gonna get down from here but i need an electric all right now i need fireworks someone give me their fireworks i don't care how you're gonna get down from here but like i i need this right your your dictator need your episode your emperor needs this sing with me sing for your sing for the left and then the other one's just electric alright do I have fireworks guys I need fireworks uh guys I need fireworks guys give me your no I meant I meant emperor emperor guys I need fireworks stop using the
fireworks I need the fireworks to fly guys guys give me your fireworks guys fireworks don't go give me that's it that's fucking it oh shit nice wait is this mine oh wait i have fireworks jk wait when did i have all of this nice okay that's that's all right i don't need any of that i have something better all right here your emperor has Giving you gifts.
Cherish this.
Wee.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Alright.
Oh yeah, you are in someone else's land.
I'm so generous.
Alright.
Let us go.
Let us go claim a land for Doki land.
I don't know where I am.
Where...
Where am I?
Mine!
Oh shit!
Put me back into the spawn!
And I shall find a land for Doki land.
Mine!
TP me too!
I'm gonna eat a tomato.
I'm hungry.
Oh, that ate nothing.
Okay, who's...
I have mod power, so I think I can kill them.
Wait.
Oh, yeah, nice.
Yeah, I can access other people's stuff.
I'm just borrowing.
Who lives here?
Oh, shit.
Okay, we don't want them to lose their bees.
Um, all right, let's see.
Who lives here right now?
All right, just so if they come back, let them know that I wrote an IOU.
Okay, wait.
Come on, give me a sign.
Put a sign in my inventory right now.
What?
Oh, shit.
Oh, where am I?
I'm at the Sound Guy Studio.
Wait, no, those are my taxes.
Where am I?
Why am I here?
Where is this place?
I'm at the Sound Guy Studio.
Okay, how did I get, how do I get out of here?
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Ow, okay.
Wait, there's nowhere to go.
Boop, boop, boop.
I'm like, where do I go?
Okay.
Boop, boop,
boop, boop.
How do I leave?
Mons!
Wait, what's this?
What do I do here?
Oh my god, I almost died.
Wait, how do I leave this area?
Oh, dude slash lobby.
Yeah, I knew that.
Alright, I'm back.
Hello.
Alright, time to claim a land for Doki land.
I gotta figure this out.
I gotta figure out where it's not claimed yet.
Is this claimed?
Israel Azzi Holy shit is that me?
Oh my god The crooky West Wing Oh my god wait Wilderness Oh my god there's a crane here Alright What is not claimed I gotta know I gotta know What is not even claimed yet?
I can't even tell.
That's a giant-ass crow.
Wait, I can't fly.
Why can't I fly?
Fly!
Oh my god, who kicked my...
Who kicked my shins?
Oh, slash L map.
Oh, this isn't claimed.
I'll claim this.
Wait, but it says it doesn't.
I can't claim anything here.
Excuse me?
Why does it say I can't claim anything?
Oh my god.
Okay, apparently...
Oh, that's the lobby.
Whoops.
Guys, I know my land, okay?
I know what I'm doing.
I know the way of Doki land, alright?
I'm not out of touch.
Of my own kingdom.
Why can't I fly anymore?
Why can't I...
Why won't I...
Why can't I fly?
I don't understand.
Let me fly!
Oh, nice.
Yay!
Alright.
I will find a land.
Surely there would be a land.
Okay, wilderness.
Parkour civilization?
Who fucking lives here?
Why is there?
There's parkour civilization.
Okay.
Maybe here?
Okay, no.
Pixel lives here.
There's a tree house.
There's a wilderness.
There's Aziz land.
Again?
How many lands do you have?
There's silent.
There's four.
Okay.
There's Aziz land again.
Wait, here!
Here!
Oh, shit.
Wait, nobody has this claim on this land.
I'll claim here.
El, Matt.
Oh my god, wait.
Okay, this is a little awkward.
Um, this is a very tight...
Oh, wait, here, here.
And then...
Mine, mine.
Alright.
Wait, what?
I can't claim one more chunk for this land.
Mons give me more land I demand more Oh shit I demand more land Just me though I Mons I demand more land Nice Wait I should have Unlimited claims Oh diamonds give me unlimited claims for my land so if i'm if i'm next to someone that i absolutely hate i'll claim one random land next to them all right don't give me mines where is my land claim
I demand more land.
Give me more land.
Toki demands more land.
Okay, wait, how do I...
Yay!
I did it.
I got more land.
See, all you gotta do is just yell mods.
Wait, whoops, L map.
Alright, where is it?
Wait, did people claim my stuff?
what happened wait where is it where is it i can't what the fuck all right ban this person time them up for a day time them out for a day that no i'll do it myself how do i time people out Oh, nice.
That's right.
TP me back.
Teach them my lesson.
TP me back to my...
I was trying to figure out how to clean my land.
Banish them for 24 hours.
Let them...
No, okay.
In the future, what we should do in the future is...
If Cloud Nord would let us, we should create a temporary server where it's like a solitary confinement and then we just banish them into that solitary confinement just making a giant white block house and everything and then like just force them to stay in there for 24 hours every time they log in and then or the only way to get out of get out of that land is to force them to is to make them um write a in a journal about what they did wrong and then have to be pre and then and then the and one of the mods will have to read um the journal and see if they learn their lesson and i think that that morally is the right thing to do all right uh anyone that kills me will get a temporary ban while i'm trying to claim this land all right i'm just saying i don't even know where i was claiming.
Like, where... Where was I claiming land?
I don't even remember.
Where is my land?
Where did it go?
Okay, um, map.
Am I here?
Where, where is it?
Oh, it's here.
Wait, how come I can't claim?
Wait, I can't claim anymore.
Where is that land?
Wait, how the fuck?
Wait, oh my god, I forgot to get my stuff.
Wait, I can't even get up.
Wait, I can't...
Okay, whoever kills me dies.
Just saying.
I'm just saying whoever kills...
Okay, who was it?
Set banish them for 24 hours!
Ha ha ha ha.
Banish them!
Where is this?
Exiting lobby.
Where am I?
You do the risk!
Okay, how do I...
Okay, I'm gonna...
How do I...
Uh...
What's the word?
Delete the lands.
i need to delete i need to delete the um the land claim because now people have claimed land around it so then i can't claim anything
sent to the void unclaimed okay slash unclaimed please go into land first in order to use you need to view oh view i'm learning my own server
I'm learning about my own server.
Set day.
Wait.
I don't know how to get back to my stuff, guys.
It's so far away.
I had to fly so far.
Okay.
Muds.
Give me God mode.
Okay.
No, when I click back, I'm here.
Moz, give me God mode.
I want to fly.
That's it.
That's fucking right.
Now I ain't playing around anymore.
That's right.
Where is that music coming from?
God is coming now.
I ain't playing.
around no more.
Also, where the fuck did I die?
The Roar.
That's right.
I'm coming for you.
Now I just need to figure out where my place was.
Where was it anyway?
Where was the area?
Wait, mod CP me to the place where I originally died.
I've lost track of where that was.
I've been flying for so long.
yeah I need I need you guys to TP me there so I can get my stuff back okay where did I die oh there it is all right nice my stuff now
okay do I unclaim from here okay slash unclaim
map okay rose why do i have so many messages who keeps sending me messages spawn edit the name manage members rose i want to unclaim this area you're trusted okay slash unclaim Did I unclaim it?
Is this my randomly claimed area?
Did I do it?
Oh, there's no claimed lands?
A map.
Just give me a sec.
I'm trying to learn my own.
I'm trying to learn my own server.
Trying to figure this out.
Where is that area that I claimed?
I claimed some fucking random patch of land and I don't know where.
Where is this random patch of land.
I claim a map.
Oh, hey, I can claim this.
I'll claim this.
Oh, failure.
Oakle is 25.
Why can't I claim it?
Oakle.
Who the fuck is Oakle?
Is that my land?
Doki land.
Oh.
Oh, I don't have money.
What the fuck?
Why don't I have money?
I'm a god.
How do I not have money?
I don't understand.
I am a god.
Wait.
I'm in someone else's land.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck is Oak all?
Oh, Darius Oak?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I... Oh, I'm so sorry.
I've... I'm in some random person's area.
Who the fuck is Darius Oak?
Who are you and why do you have... Why am I part of your society?
I... No, I gave you...
Oops, sorry.
Leave my society, Oak!
I'm gonna unclaim your land now.
I mean, I can't claim this.
Unclaimed.
That's right, I'm unclaiming your land.
Wait, L.A., okay.
Unclaimed.
Unclaim.
I'll claim all your lands.
Oh, nice.
Oops.
Sorry.
Oh, cool.
I'm not sorry.
I... That's right.
If you trust me on your land, I will unclaim your land.
Don't test me.
Don't test this god.
Okay.
El map.
All right.
Now.
Yay.
Wait.
Is this O'Kill?
Darius?
Wait, why am I still part of your land?
This land isn't looking for new members.
What the fuck?
I actually claimed this land again.
Oh my god, that's it.
Is this also...
Okay, okay.
Unclaimed.
How dare you?
This is gonna be...
My land, Toki, no.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now that that's gone, who's here?
Who is here?
Okay, this is a random unclaim.
Do L delete land name trust?
Oh, L delete oak hole.
Wait, does that delete everything?
Oh, trust.
Okay, there you go.
Oko trust.
I was about to delete this entire person's place.
Wait.
Land solidly.
Oko confirmed.
Oh, you should not have trusted me, Oko.
I could have deleted your entire land claim.
Okay.
Map.
Is this mine now?
Why am I still claiming land for Orkul?
Who is he?
Get me out of your society!
Why am I still claiming land for you?
Get out!
No way, you're nowhere near me.
Do slash edit.
Slash.
l edit okay there's no claim view l create dokeyland all right you do not need it oh l create dokey let dokey land the sequel actually no dokey blonde all right nice what the fuck Oh my god, it's in the sky.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Oh my god, I've actually put it now.
Nobody can get my storage.
I need to use the bathroom.
Your back, guys.
Emperor is back.
Okay, how do I put the storage below?
I think it's a little inconvenient.
Just a little.
Oh, just a little bit.
Let's see.
How do I...
Okay, I own all of this, right?
Oh, no, these are the wilderness.
Okay, oh.
Oh, I guess I own that random paw area, too.
So how do I...
Slash, edit, do L, set, spawn?
Okay, I'll set spawn right here.
Set L slash set spawn.
spot.
I'm not out of touch with my people.
Oh my gosh, am I lagging?
Why am I lagging?
Okay, what is causing my lag?
Okay, wait.
I gotta figure this out.
Have I been lagging this entire time?
Okay, details.
Oh, I have?
Okay, did I set my spawn?
Where is it?
Wait, where did my thing go?
Is it still up top?
Okay.
Uh.
There we go.
Alright.
Let's set spawn.
Slash, set, spell, set, spawn.
Cost.
Zero dollars.
Yes, I have that money.
L-edit.
L-set spawn.
What do you mean?
It costs $0.
Let me set my spawn!
Remove this!
This I don't understand!
Alright, video settings.
Maybe I'll set my frame weight.
Why do I have 240 on 4?
Fucking...
Wait.
Reduce.
FPS.
Use no anime.
Only use entity.
And use not inside a visible chunk.
CP.
I don't know.
I can't read any of this.
I can't break it.
Land.
Open.
I'm trying to put this at the bottom.
I can't put this.
I don't know why I'm lagging.
Is it because, like, everyone's around me why am i lagging wait that's weird let me double check it says my yeah everything is under a hundred huh is it too many players on me
wait how can they build on my land oh it's literally outside it's just outside Oh map
Okay now they can't do shit
Okay now they can't do anything
I want to put this at the bottom Oh edit left block Oh nice okay
Alright how do I and then I put this here Oh no that's just an egg Okay, slash L edit.
L set spot.
How come...
Oh, how do I...
Now, what do I do?
What do I do after that?
It's gone.
My main storage is just gone.
It's just...
It disappeared.
It's L edit.
Land.
L map.
Where did it go?
It disappeared.
My land disappeared.
Also, I'm claiming this too.
Fuck you guys.
Oh.
L L.
Storage.
wait where did it go though where did my storage go L storage wait how do I claim it how do I put my thing down guys how do I'm not out of touch with the people I swear to God then right it's L map And then right click.
Oh, here you go.
Yay!
I got my stuff back.
Oh.
Yay!
All right.
Now, how do I kill everybody that's on my land?
This is very important.
How do...
What is the kill command to kill everybody that's on my land?
Wait.
No.
I need to know.
You know what?
If I have a golem,
it's slash slash kill
at no, I want to know anyone that's on my land.
Not, oh, at P?
At P.
Where is Where's my land?
Look at this.
Where's my body?
Mods!
Banish the person that said that!
For 24 hours!
Banish him!
Slashing kills.
Eh.
What happened?